Anyone working at the SCP Foundation will
no doubt be familiar with SCP-3008, also known
as the Infinite Ikea.
For those of you that aren’t, it essentially
does what it says on the can – or rather,
it’s assembled just like it is in the flat
pack furniture instructions.
While, on the outside, it appears to be an
average, unassuming branch of the affordable
Swedish furniture outlet, inside is a different
story.
Crossing the boundary of SCP-3008’s automatic
doors and venturing a little too deep into
its maze-like confines leads to an endless
labyrinth of Kullens and Hurdals, a dimensionally
transcendental area that defies our ordinary
human understanding of physical space.
Lurking deep within the aisles of the Infinite
Ikea are SCP-3008-2s, better known as ‘The
Staff’, a race of misshapen faceless humanoids,
with long, freakish arms that prey on anyone
that enters once night falls.
And yes, there are people inside SCP-3008,
trapped souls that have wandered into the
wrong Ikea, only to end up missing, sometimes
spending months or even years inside, if they
ever get out at all.
An alert was ringing, filling the air with
loud, blaring noise.
Every member of Foundation personnel stationed
outside the Infinite Ikea was rushing about,
guards standing at the ready.
The storefront of SCP-3008 had been silent
for quite a long while, with nothing reported
going in or coming out.
But the Foundation knew far better than to
assume that SCP-3008 didn’t have surprises
in store for them – pun fully intended.
Hey, don’t you dare click off!
We know where you live and Red Right Hand
are lining up the shot!
Ahem, anyway.
There appeared to be some kind of commotion
beyond the doors, that quickly slid open,
just in time for something to be slung through
the front entrance.
It almost looked as if the Ikea itself had
spat something out, like it was so toxic it
couldn’t endure having to keep in within
its confines any longer.
Cautiously, approaching with their weapons
raised, the Foundation’s on-site security
team moved towards the discarded mess to get
a better look at whatever it was.
It turned out to be a person, a man in around
his late fifties, beaten within an inch of
his life.
He was wearing some kind of rudimentary circlet
or crown around his head, seemingly fashioned
by hand out of stationary and other materials
scavenged from the ‘Paper Shop’ department
of the Infinite Ikea.
Speaking of, the man was wearing an Ikea manager’s
uniform, with a name tag pinned to his chest
that identified him as ‘Kris’.
Hanging from his neck was an Ikea branded
notepad, with a message scrawled on it…
But before you find out what that message
was, we have another important message for
you, one that directly impacts you…
Yes I’m talking directly to YOU!
It comes from the sponsor of today’s video,
Private Internet Access.
We know you’ve heard a lot of big claims
from a lot of different VPN providers, but
you absolutely must hear why we’ve chosen
PIA as our personal VPN, and why you should
do the same.
Unlike the SCP Foundation, and some of those
other VPN services out there, PIA is the world’s
most transparent VPN provider.
They never record or store any user data at
all.
Don’t believe us?
Their no-log policy has been proven multiple
times in court and was even verified by an
independent audit by Deloitte
And they stay transparent so that you don’t
have to.
With PIA’s VPN, your IP address is hidden
and your connection is encrypted, keeping
your digital life protected from the prying
eyes of network admins or even a certain Mobile
Task Force unit.
And they’ve just launched what is maybe
their coolest feature yet.
With servers now in all 50 US states, you
can look like you’re surfing the web from
exactly where you want.
Need to look like you’re checking out that
SCP database entry from Indiana?
They’ve got an IP address for you there.
Or maybe you’re on the west coast and want
to catch the early east coast premiere of
your favorite show and avoid spoilers.
Not a problem with Private Internet Access.
I could go on and on about all the features
I regularly use, but why not try it yourself
by going to https://www.piavpn.com/SCP and
get an 82% discount on Private Internet Access!
That's just $2.11 a month, plus get 3 extra
months completely for free!
Not long before Kris was found in his roughed-up
state outside the only Ikea that goes on forever,
he was working at a different branch, one
that was much smaller on the inside.
Kris was the manager of the store, and widely
regarded, by his employees, to be an awful
person.
Nobody knew if he had always been that way,
or if instilling him in a position of power
over other retail workers had somehow caused
him to develop a bit of a god complex.
Either way, there was little he ever did to
invoke much comradery with his colleagues.
Whenever any of the store’s workers were
on their breaks – which they usually had
to remind Kris were permitted by law, and
not optional – conversation often turned
to their collective poor opinions of the manager.
He’d been given the job out of pretty blatant
nepotism; it was well-known how cosy Kris
was with the regional manager of all the Ikea
stores in the area.
On top of that, Kris had a pretty nasty habit
of trying to force his employees to stay behind
after their scheduled shifts had finished,
while also refusing to pay them for overtime.
You see, it was his own mismanagement of the
work rota that left the store understaffed
at crucial moments of the day.
The solution, you would think, should be obvious:
hiring a few more new staff to help with the
workload and to start their shifts at times
when others were about to clock out for the
day.
Ah, but new employees wouldn’t work for
free, their wages would come out of the store’s
budget.
And why would Kris want to take on new workers?
As the person in charge of payroll, he could
help himself to that money, adding the wages
of prospective colleagues as a bonus on top
of his own unjustifiably exorbitant salary.
Perhaps the worst part about having Kris as
a manager was that he seemed to get away with
murder.
As long as the store kept making a profit,
then the management above him didn’t care
how badly he treated his employees or flouted
the rules for his own gain.
But it was those same colleagues who had suffered
and been scorned by Kris’ behaviour who
had finally had enough.
Retail work is hard, having to deal with rude
and impolite customers on a day to day basis,
working long hours of uninteresting and repetitive
labour, all for a pay check that only just
covered rent.
Like we said, it’s a hard line of work,
and the people in it deserve the utmost respect.
But you throw a megalomaniacal manager into
the mix, and you’ve got a ticking time bomb
on your hands, one that’ll sooner or later
explode.
It was witnessing Kris blatantly framing a
younger member of staff that finally triggered
detonation.
The kid had only been a student, working at
Ikea all through his weekends to make enough
money to pay his bills.
Kris saw this less experienced employee not
as a human being doing his best, but a chance
to make a quick buck by breaking the rules.
The manager started stealing cash from the
register, then blamed it on his young staff
member when the losses started to show on
the store’s monthly financial reports.
Seeing that for themselves, the other members
of staff knew it was the manager’s responsibility
to empty the registers regularly, so they
didn’t have too much cash in them in case
of a robbery.
Given how much they all despised Kris, it
didn’t take much effort for the entire workforce
to organise a walk-out, halfway through the
working day.
Outraged, Kris had tried calling any colleagues
that were off-shift, barking at them to come
in and work on their days off.
All of them said no.
The thing is, when you work in retail, complaints
to upper management never seem to go anywhere.
Like we said, if the store’s making profit,
that’s all they care about.
But seeing such drastic action from the staff
of the store he was supposed to be running,
the Ikea higher-ups came down on Kris like
a hammer.
They instructed that he be sent to another
Ikea outlet for a whole afternoon, to receive
some mandatory interpersonal training.
Little did anyone realize that this was the
last anyone would ever see of him – not
that his old staff was sad to hear he had
disappeared.
Arriving at what looked like an ordinary Ikea,
Kris parked his car outside.
The place seemed deserted, no customers filing
in and out of the front doors, the only other
vehicles in the parking lot looking like they
had just been abandoned by their owners.
The manager scoffed to himself.
These people running this store were going
to teach him how to do his job?
Indignantly, he clipped his name tag on and
stepped out of his car, marching across the
asphalt towards the entrance.
The automatic doors gently slid open, shutting
smoothly behind Kris as he stepped inside.
The whole store was quiet, barely a peep from
anywhere.
The high ceiling of the Ikea store he so poorly
managed carried a lot of noise and made any
sound echo throughout the building.
The squeaking of shoes against the vinyl floors,
the bustle of customers, the electronic beep
of cash registers, and the low, dulled music
playing over the intercom.
But there was none of that here.
A deathly silence filled the aisles of flat
pack furniture, display models of Hemneses
and Trysils standing as still and foreboding
as gravestones.
Suddenly, the sound of movement reverberated
from between one row of aisles.
Kris began marching towards its source, expecting
to find an employee who could point him in
the direction of the office where his training
was supposed to be conducted.
Sure enough, within a few steps, Kris spotted
a figure in a familiar bright yellow t-shirt
and blue pants; the same uniform his Ikea
underlings wore at his store.
“Excuse me,” he called as he strode towards
the employee, shoes clomping against the floor
with every step.
“You need to tell me where your manager
is, I’m from the store across town.
Here for some pointless training seminar.”
Kris hadn’t waited until he was close enough
to engage in pleasant conversation, instead
making his demands as he approached.
The figure in the Ikea uniform, however, didn’t
turn to face him.
“Hey!
I’m talking to you!”
Kris shouted.
“You deaf or something?”
There was a pause, telling Kris that what
happened next wasn’t in response to what
he said; although that didn’t make it any
less frightening.
The figure, who had been hunched over near
the floor, suddenly drew itself up to its
full height.
It towered over Kris, it must have measured
close to seven whole feet.
As it turned, the malignant manager saw its
face… or that it didn’t have one.
No eyes, no mouth, nothing but a smooth surface
without any discernible features.
Its arms were elongated, huge, claw-like hands
hanging down to the creature’s knees.
Being a coward, Kris turned and ran immediately.
Confrontation was another area his employees
had noticed he was sorely lacking in; whenever
faced with a rude and cantankerous customer,
Kris would never defend his colleagues or
their actions.
Instead, he would suck up and brownnose to
customers who were clearly in the wrong, essentially
rolling over the minute anyone raised their
voice.
So, now confronted with a lumbering, faceless
entity, his self-preservation instincts were
kicked into overdrive, and he raced deeper
into the store.
Not exactly in the best shape, he slowed to
a halt, wheezing as he tried to catch his
breath.
That was when, looking around, Kris noticed
just how long the aisle seemed.
He was sure he would still be able to see
the front door from here, yet couldn’t spot
the entrance anywhere from where he was currently
standing, panting like a thirsty dog.
He looked over his shoulder; there was no
sign of the Staff member he’d encountered.
Little did Kris know that it had lumbered
off in the opposite direction the second he
had run away from it, hardly paying him any
mind…
at least, while the lights were still on.
Unable to find the entrance, or even a fire
door he could escape through, it didn’t
take long for the lights inside the Infinite
Ikea to dim, marking the start of the night
cycle.
Something about it being darker made the sounds
of shuffling even more noticeable…
there were more than one of those faceless,
uniformed creatures.
Trembling, Kris climbed inside a Kleppstad,
a wardrobe with a sliding door.
Barely able to sleep with his knees tucked
up under his chin, he spent the entire night
inside the cramped, confined space.
Every sound of movement from outside brought
with it the mental image of one of the Staff
sliding open the outer door and reaching down
to grab him.
The whole sleepless while, Kris couldn’t
help but think about what he could have possibly
done to deserve this cruel fate.
The next morning, the lights came back on
and started to bleed through the seams of
the flat pack wardrobe, waking Kris from what
little restless sleep he had gotten.
He paused, unsure if he should venture out
in case he came across another one of the
Staff.
Suddenly, he heard the sound of voices, muted
and muffled by the door of the Kleppstad,
but definitely real human voices.
Had it all been some horrible nightmare?
Had he fallen asleep at work and been stuffed
into a wardrobe by his ungrateful employees?
Oh, now he had them, he would sue every last
one of them out of their jobs.
Sliding the door open and tumbling out of
the Kleppstad, Kris’ found himself lying
face down on the store floor, his legs too
cramped to move.
Just as he tried to will them into moving
again, a voice called out to him.
“Hey, mister!”
it said.
“You okay there?”
A trio of footsteps raced over to where he
was, and before he could get good look at
who they belonged to, hands were pulling Kris
up off the floor.
He looked at his rescuers, bemused to see
other people in this endless void of affordable
home wear.
They were two men and a woman, each in disheveled
clothing that looked like they had been wearing
the same thing for years.
“Easy there, fella,” one of the men spoke.
“Name’s Buster, which settlement you from?”
“What…
what do you mean by ‘settlement’?”
Kris asked, confused.
“Looks like we got another newbie,” the
woman chuckled dryly.
“When did you get here?”
“Yesterday, I think,” the former manager
answered.
“Time can be a bit screwy in here,” the
second man chimed in.
“I’m Nolan.
This here is Janine.
You got a name?”
“Kris,” he nodded.
“You hungry, Kris?”
Buster offered.
The three survivors led Kris through the winding
expanse of the Ikea without an end, navigating
the identical aisles with the expertise of
people that had been here long enough to know
their way around.
In what felt like the tiniest fraction of
the time that he had been lost the day before,
they brought Kris to the food court.
It was bustling with activity, more so than
the one at his store, with people patiently
lining up to take their fill of food from
the Ikea menu.
After joining the queue, Buster returned and
handed Kris a plate of Swedish meatballs with
mashed potato, peas, cream sauce, and lingonberry
jam.
So pleased to see food again, Kris began to
gluttonously devour the whole plate while
the others explained some of what was going
on here; although he was barely listening.
According to Janine, who had been there the
longest, the inside of this Ikea was like
an endless maze, there was no clear way out,
even when retracing steps back the way one
first entered.
Nolan then weighed in and explained that there
were pockets of people who had survived this
long inside SCP-3008 by forming their own
little communities.
Thanks to the sheer amount of space within
the store, these settlements were almost the
size of small townships, built using whatever
furniture, appliances, and other materials
the other survivors had been able to scrounge
up.
“How come you don’t run out of food?”
Kris interjected.
“It replenishes every day, man,” Buster
replied, gesturing to the food court around
them.
“Sure, it’s not ideal if you aren’t
a huge fan of Ikea food.
But you get used to it.
Could be worse, all things considered.”
“Then what the hell do you all do for money?”
the suborn manager demanded.
“Look around you,” Janine scoffed.
“We don’t need it in here.
We’re cut off from the rest of the world,
stuff like money hardly makes a difference.
It can’t get us home, or keep us fed, so
what’s the point?”
Kris sighed, evidently frustrated at the prospect
of living inside an Ikea yet not having the
opportunity for monetary gain.
“So, who’s in charge?” he asked.
“Who runs this place?”
“No one,” Nolan shrugged.
“The settlements all work together, help
each other out if needed.
But we don’t have any singular person running
things.”
Hearing that out loud caused a twisted idea
to form in Kris’ balding head.
Asking to be escorted by Buster to the right
aisle, he started gathering up what he needed
to make a rudimentary crown.
“What’s that for?”
Buster asked, a little concerned about what
Kris was planning.
“Oh, you wouldn’t understand,” he replied,
not looking up from applying hot glue.
“Don’t worry, I’ll explain it in nice,
simple terms when I’m ready.”
That night, despite being welcomed into the
trio’s town of ‘Lighting’ with open
arms, Kris slipped back to the food court
while the other settlers were sleeping.
Carefully, he avoided the lurking Staff, and
their droned calls of ‘The store is now
closed, please exit the building’.
Reaching his destination, the malicious manager
lay in wait for the next morning, hiding out
underneath the counter where the food was
served.
The next morning, the collected survivors
of the Infinite Ikea were met with an unfamiliar
sight as they approached the food court.
All the food had gone, it had still replenished
overnight like it usually did, but someone
had gathered it up before anyone had a chance
to eat.
Stood atop the counter with a smug look on
his face, Kris made a show of placing his
crown over his head.
“Morning everyone!” he announced.
“From today, things are going to be a little
different around here.
But I’m sure we’ll all be able to work
together like one big, happy family.”
Holding the gathered SCP-3008 residents as
his literally captive audience, all of them
hungry and irritable, Kris outlined what he
had determined to be the best system possible
for how things should be run inside the endless
store.
“I will keep all the food secure and safe,
and we’re going to start rationing it out,”
he explained.
“What for?”
a voice shouted from the crowd.
“It reappears every night anyway!”
“Well, here’s what we’re going to do,
if you’ll just shut up and let me finish,”
Kris replied calmly, but with a condescending
tone of superiority.
According to Kris’ grand scheme, every day
each settlement would be allocated what he
deemed to be an acceptable amount of rationed
food to feed its population of survivors.
Then, he made an offer to anyone who was willing
to help him.
If someone provided their services in collecting
the food each morning and distributing the
rationed amount, then Kris would allow them
to take an extra portion of rations just for
themselves.
“You see now?” he asked the crowd, oblivious
to how many of them were scowling at him.
“Anyone that wants to help, they get rewarded
with a little bit extra.
Call it a bonus!”
“What if we don’t want to help you?”
another onlooker called.
“That’s fine by me,” Kris sneered back.
“More for those who want it!”
“I think, what they mean is,” Janine shouted
from the group.
“What if we don’t want you to implement
this ridiculous system at all?
What’s to stop us just taking the food we
need every morning like we did before you
showed up?”
“Typical,” he tutted.
“How lazy.
You want the privilege of having more, then
you should work to earn it!
And as for your silly notion of just taking,
I’m going to be here every morning.
I’ll get to decide who eats and who doesn’t,
and how much they deserve.
And if anyone wants to take more than they
deserve, without offering their help in return,
then they’ll get half of the rations they
would get.
And so will their settlement.
So, with those queries out of the way, allow
me to introduce myself as your new store manager!”
When they recovered Kris’ body outside the
entrance to SCP-3008, the Foundation had no
way of knowing exactly who had beaten him
up so badly.
The other survivors inside the Infinite Ikea
might have done it themselves, while overthrowing
his short-lived stint as manager.
Or they might have decided not to lower themselves
to that level, and instead shunned him from
entering their settlements, leaving him to
fend for himself.
With the Staff around every corner, and their
history of turning aggressive towards humans
come nightfall, Kris’ chances of survival
were slim.
The only real clue was the note that had been
found with him, which read:
‘You can have him back.
We don’t want him.’
Now, if you aren’t quite ready to checkout
of the Infinite Ikea, then you should go and
check out “LIFE IN THE ENDLESS IKEA” for
another tale of a trapped soul in SCP-3008.
And then, if you ever want suggestions on
what to do if you find yourself in the same
predicament, then “HOW TO ACTUALLY BEAT
SCP-3008 THE INFINITE IKEA” is the only
survival guide you’ll ever need!